uh let me start with congratulations I'm
sure you're hearing that from everyone
who is joint doing your speed dating
today
thank you it's very werewolf by night is
very good fans are going to love it um I
love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of shows movies
um what do you think would surprise
Marvel fans to learn about the actual
making of werewolf by night I think the
fact that it was
um a really what felt like a really
creatively free environment that we were
filming in you know I I didn't expect
that and I thought that filming in the
MCU would be kind of stricter you know
you've got to make sure that these
things all line up together everything's
connected and I always thought that you
know I wouldn't be able to change a word
of a script but actually it was
something that felt much more
collaborative than that and we kind of
felt like we were creating this little
you know Indie movie um just like a
little passion project and I kept having
to remind myself that it was part of
this bigger context because it just felt
really fun and really easy going I was
very surprised at the level of there was
more violence and blood than I was
expecting going in because the MC
YouTube typically doesn't show that were
you a little bit like are we really
gonna do this oh
yeah I was pushing for it all the way I
guess a bit
um but I didn't know until I saw the
piece myself how much of that we you
know we how much we won that and uh I
was thrilled to see you know the blood
splatter
when you were getting involved in this
did you know what you were auditioning
for or what you were meeting on or were
they very mysterious no no it was it was
mysterious but quick so I didn't have to
audition
um the casting director and Michael our
director had known my work from before
so it was a zoom conversation with
Michael but I didn't know what that Zoom
conversation was going to be about until
like until I got on so I think I knew
that it was going to be a Halloween
special and that's all I knew and then I
came on and he told me about what the
piece was going to be and the tribute
that he wanted to pay to you know the
old movies and and who else I was so I
mean at that point I was extra thrilled
because I kind of would have done
anything but the MCU wanted me to do but
to know that there was something that
was so in my wheelhouse was very
exciting did he ask you to watch any
vintage movies or any things to get
ready for the role he didn't have to I'd
watch them all already I grew up on that
stuff so he and I really connected
um you know over that on our on our
first meeting and when he said that he
wanted to pay tribute to those I was
like able to you know talk about them
all and we were talking about which ones
were our favorite ones and everything
and uh yeah I just I think I really
understood what it was that he was
trying to create so you know that that
uh that put us off in a good foot I
think what are you actually most excited
for MC MCU fans Marvel fans to see in
the special
gosh I mean I'm I mean I'm so excited
about the whole thing because it does
feel so unique you know it feels like a
really fresh take for Marvel and
uh you know I think the fact that it is
horror the fact it is scary and there
are those shocks and a bit of that Gore
in there but it's also a story that's
really you know human it's really rooted
in in uh humanity and the Heart of it
and the kind of metaphor between the
internal monster and the external one
and you know so I love that it has those
layers so I just yeah you know hoping I
hope when a few people get a few
nightmares but in the end I hope they
take away from it you know something
about the connection between the
characters
on that note I got to stop I'm just
going to say congrats uh I really do
believe it turned out great oh thanks so
much